[Music]
joe let's talk about your
favorite person in the world kim
jong-un i was like where's this going
i saw a collage of many people 41
nice piece that's true but none of them
does kim jong-un top the list for you it
depends on his mood dude
dan lok is one dan lok is pretty dope
that's true that's true man i
there's just ah there's just so many
people in this world to look up to and
appreciate
and um you know want to be friends with
with a fond eye yeah
it's it's very difficult to just choose
one you know they're like pokemon i want
them all
gotta have them all man would you would
you be uh friends with kim jong-un
if uh let's just say he's ordering
all pet dogs to be confiscated in north
korea why because of kovid
no he's just he okay he wants to keep
him for himself doesn't he
i hope so i don't even think people
don't
exactly know why he's doing this and
there's
con there's conspiracies about different
reasons why
i don't even know they're allowed to
have a dog there that's like a lot more
privilege than i think exactly right
i was surprised by that too but one of
the things that he has said is that
dogs being a dog owner is a western
decadence
and so by by nature of that we should uh
north koreans should not be dog owners
and
and and boycott this western decadence
we should not own dogs but we should own
monkeys
that's a north korean thing is that a
north korean thing no boat that'll be
funny if you want to choose a different
animal
picture kim jong-un with a [ __ ]
monkey this is a korean
you get a betta fish in the little jar
yeah oh yeah and then put it put it next
to another beta fish so they can just
fight that's a sick idea are there any
korean pets cause i know old-school
chinese people have like
a cricket or grasshopper in a box that's
supposed to be they had jiminy crickets
yeah they would carry a little box with
like a grasshopper cricket in it hey
they do that in mexico too but they eat
them oh yeah they're like we put them in
we put them in what they're called no
they're called um
what's the mexican translation the
spanish
or crickets yeah uh grillos no
cricatos i saw i have a i have a friend
who
tied not not kidding tied floss around a
june bug
and flew like oh yeah that's a mexican
thing for sure too or a hood thing
really never seen that in my life yeah
you just put a string on them and then
they fly so it's like a kite
that was i don't know like you're
walking the dog but a bug
and you're just blind yeah it was like
that it was wild
you guys have uh uh uh is it fireflies
yeah you guys have fireflies growing up
they don't we don't have fireworks
here though we used to capture fireflies
in a little jar and we like carried
around i didn't know they were real
until i saw them in 2017 in maryland i
thought they were
like mythical they they do seem that way
they do seem that way it's like so like
it's because
it's real life yeah it's like summer's
in virginia you just see the whole
[ __ ]
woods light up so sick i missed that i
missed that like it's
me too maybe it's like the humid places
yes
yeah it's too dry out here to have maybe
they don't want to be like it's too dry
i don't want to be here we don't have
that in hawaii it's humid there they
didn't happen
maybe they didn't fly there yeah exactly
we should send them there because
they're so pretty
we get a bunch of dragonflies right now
they're like [ __ ] huge that's pretty
cool and they're so
curious about like like there was one
that was near him and then one that like
a huge fat one like this far away i was
like going like this
land on me they're all right but they
don't glow
that's true they they do they're kind of
rainbowy there's blue ones there's red
ones
cool colors but if you're in the dark
you're you're [ __ ] out of luck though i
flashed a flashlight at them i saw some
in new jersey they went
fireflies yeah oh nine and it was pat's
first experience they're like is that a
firefly
i'm like nah it's just neon bullets
stupid pat and then pat couldn't enjoy
it anymore
but yeah so back to kim jong-un uh so
this is
uh old news i guess because apparently
he they made this announcement back in
july but i guess
coming from north korea you know news
gets out a little slower
than the rest of the world so we're just
now learning about the fact that
uh kim jong-un has ordered authorities
to
identify households that have dogs as
pets
and they go in forcing them to give them
up or they're forcefully confiscating
them
and then putting them down on the spot
on the spot
yeah but it seems like there's like
mixed mixed reporting and
like sometimes they're putting them down
then and there and sometimes they're
just confiscating them
just when you thought north korea
couldn't get any less fun exactly just
got a little less fun
wow they have a theme park who gets to
go there just kim jong-un
just the people that pretend no dogs
allowed they're having fun when tourists
come to
so so they could the tourists can see
how fun north korea is
wait so if you go there every single day
it's the same actors there
i'm making that up because you know how
there's a whole thing where like they're
acting whatever yeah um the internet
cafe [ __ ] is
the most funny [ __ ] were they pretending
to play
they did clearly never been on the
keyboard in their lives and just
but yeah so some of the confiscated dogs
are also headed to
the korea central zoo in pyongyang
and also they also have animal
sanctuaries uh i ironically enough right
like they're putting the
dogs down but they're also sending some
of them to animal sanctuaries
uh and then obviously there's the
concept of them being on dinner tables
and
uh dog meat is a popular food in north
korea
according to this report and recent food
shortage uh shortage
uh maybe because of the camp pandemic
and all has made it more viable
to just eat dog dog meat now so there's
a lot of reasons why
dogs are being confiscated uh and then
the bourgeois
ideology of being a dog owner seems to
be kind of like
the the craziest one but then there's
other economical means as to why they're
being confiscated you know what's crazy
about like the need to belong
family and brainwashing so like
everyone here everyone thinks like north
korea is the [ __ ] craziest worst
place why would you ever want to be
there right
so like most defectors they do all that
[ __ ] work
to get out but then they end up going
back
damn so is that like a what's it called
stockholm stockholm syndrome
i don't know if it's necessarily that
but it could be
well it's because a lot of them get
ostracized even in like south korea
like well they'll leave and even if
they're in different countries like
china
and then they have all the food that
they want all this stuff right but then
they miss
how life was they missed their family
they missed like
all these things and then i would miss
my family yeah
so even though it's better quote-unquote
like better like there's more
things right but their quality of the
life of life is not the same so they end
up just going back you have to get
worried about going back now that you
escaped like that you'd be
in trouble i don't know but they a lot
of them go back though they also get
really discriminated against
in the countries that they end up going
to because they're north korean
and you're a defector well no no no it's
more like
like you're you're short like you're an
immigrant you're like um oh i think
yeah like you're not from here yeah
exactly not one
like well so they're so malnourished
that the difference between north
koreans and south koreans are like
they're so much shorter
there's height differences now north
koreans are a lot shorter and they're
like
they they just look different because
they speak different
generations of being malnourished like
laughing at a hillbilly then
right basically that's what it sounds
like that's crazy
the most ironic thing out of this whole
dog situation though
is that kim jong-un he gets to have him
just gets german
he's a big fan of dogs he has his own
dogs and uh
he you hypocrite he has this collection
of shih tzus
german shepherds and other like exotic
breeds and
his dad also kim jong-il also had a lot
of dogs and he also famously gifted
peace puppies to the south korean
president back in 2018
so the idea that he's getting rid of all
dogs in north korea yet he's also
you know keeping the best dogs for
himself it's all kind of just
points out the fact that he's a [ __ ]
dictator well that's the benefits of
being a dictator
get to be a hypocrite he takes me for
like a a pug kind of guy
or like a bull yeah yeah maybe a bulldog
yeah he takes you for a pug kind of guy
or you take him
i take him he's like you know that jojo
tsukawa
he's a pug guy he's a yeah he's he's a
he's
very that kind of guy yeah it's like uh
uh 101 dalmatians the opening sequence
you guys remember that movie
i forgot where like the dogs looking out
the window and then there's like dog
uh owners walking their dogs like that
they all look like the dog
the dog vice versa looks like the owner
that's why panda and perdita were so
pretty
isn't that funny when you see that
though when when you see like somebody
that looks like their daughter
my mom hated that because my mom has
like blonde curly hair and we step a
cocker spaniel and they have
long curly like hair on their ears and
she would not
walk that dog because we had a beagle
and we had a cocker spaniel and she's
like i'm not walking that
dog i don't want to look like him so
that's like a big thing in mexican like
really i want a match with my nose my uh
dad and my
dog bowser kind of look a little like
like they're the same eyes like the same
like
like soft eyes that's awesome yeah i
don't want a dog that doesn't match me
true what would it be a dog they're my
accessory man
i want a girl who looks like a dog oh
yeah me too yeah but if it's a cute dog
though what if the dog looks like a girl
oh [ __ ] the dog's gonna get it
like that one with the lassie dog it's
kind of like a lassie dog
but it has a long hair a border collie
yeah oh yeah looking like madonna and
[ __ ]
those things are i can't believe those
are real it looks like a wig is stapled
to them yeah
it's true afghanistan always calm down
right yeah afghan hound i'm so happy we
have internet now i know right
oh [ __ ] yeah oh look at this one
look at that one i told you they're hot
i know which one's the dog in the three
no yeah which is the dog
she kind of they look like fawn right
now but with like like we put a wig on
that's true oh i miss fun
she's home she's all right she's not
yeah it sounds like she's dead yeah that
did sound like that
she's so scared she's so scared
for no reason it's the funniest dog in
the world yeah she's really funny
always acting like you're gonna beat her
ass up yeah she's traumatized she's a
rescue
so they probably did beat her ass up
she's she's like a lot better now though
every time i do visit it's like she's
opening up more not anymore because we
got this new bug zapper
as soon as it zaps a bug it's just
[ __ ] jet skies trying to go into the
pool
how did you get how did you get fun from
a dog dog shelter but is that the one
where you looked in the eyes no that's
me
though okay is there a similar story to
that with fawn
i think she looked her in the ice you
had a connection with five yeah so the
so when we
so we had tyson at the time and then uh
what happened
my previous dog passed away because she
was 15 or something so she passed away
just she didn't like us in the ice
and then meatloaf was just left by
himself and i like having my husband
sorry tyson was uh left alone i like
having my dogs in pears
so then we and he's a senior dog at this
point so then we went to the shelter
and then we started um they started
bringing out different dogs like a
speedster
so that it could match tyson's
personality and temperament and stuff
so they brought a first one out and they
already started kind of fighting a
little bit
and then fawn came out and then he like
tried to intimidate her and she was like
nah [ __ ] but she was like still
beta so she's like alpha like in the
middle between like elephant and a
better dude
each other in the eyes yeah so she
checked him a little bit but then she
was still very like dainty
and i'm like you could be dominant i'll
be submissive but i'm gonna be bullied
i won't be bullied and i like that about
her that's the perfect relationship
perfect so that's what happened nice but
she would pee
if someone tried to pet her yeah it was
bad in a corner
i'll be like hi doggy and she'll be like
and i'm like oh she peed all over the
damn floor man
she's come a long way that's how my
sister-in-law's dog was but out of
excitement
she was like so excited that people were
here that she'd just pee everywhere
everywhere
she's running on the couches and on the
floor and peeing on everything
we're just like please stop it and we're
like so we had to get it it got to the
point where no matter who comes over
it's like don't say hi to the dog
don't make her happy you're gonna have
to look at her just like she's not there
it's like running all over and then you
like after 10 minutes you can like say
hi and then it's
more time i remember the first time i
seen bart
uh with meatloaf with tyson because he
would pee all the places he was just old
right
and i've never seen anyone grab their
dog's dick
so they would stop peeing because you
would do that all the time like what's
up you pinched it and then you saw this
thing getting gorged
no no no no i grab it and i take them
outside and let it go and it was almost
like a water balloon goes
damn especially here we got carpet all
over the place true
that's what those stains over there are
you guys see them in what joe's frame
oh really that's what that's all the
dogs that do here yeah we had a ton of
dogs you've got like four or five dogs
here at once
the dog bathroom that's true not on
[Music]
purpose
you